There once was a very special boy.
He was very, very hungry.
He was so hungry that a bowl of alphabet soup wouldn't do.
He pushed it away.
No soup for him.
He wanted more.
This special boy wanted a special sandwich.
Not some peanut butter and jiggly jelly jam sandwich.
Not a little kid's sandwich.
He wanted a grown-up sandwich.
A gigantic, mountain high kind of sandwich.
And so this boy closed his eyes and made a very special wish.
He made a sandwich sandwish.
First, he sandwished a loaf of bread hot from the oven.
He cut off a slice so big. He had to use a saw instead of a knife.
Cheese was next, but not just one kind.
He wished for cheddar, Swiss, and Monterey jack.
He wished for a big glob of cheese spread.
Then he wished for meat roast beef, ham, chicken, and turkey.
He had to stop in the middle and sandwish for a ladder.
He climbed it to pile on more.
He slapped on lettuce, a fresh tomato, and pickles.
He added relish and a slice of eye-watering onion.
Up and down the ladder of wishes he climbed.
He piled on more and more.
He finally had to sandwish a crane to drop on the last slice of bread.
There it was!
It was a mile high monster meal.
It was a sandwished sandwich like no other sandwich wished for before.
This special boy was ready to eat.
But where could he start?
He walked around and around, looking up and down.
There was no way to start eating this sandwich.
There was no way to end.
The very special boy leaned up against the sandwich.
He closed his eyes and made yet another sandwish.
He wished for alphabet soup, please, and a sandwich of peanut butter and jiggly jelly jam.
He ate it all and filled his tummy.
He whispered softly, "Thanks. That was yummy.".